[Music]
i love all these
toys
[Music]
don't replay with this stuff
how did you see the world when you were
a kid
[Music]
is there such thing as girls toys or
boys toys or can kids have fun with any
toys
we invited five kids to a playroom
filled with toys
not typically associated with their
gender
how much do you like toys um a hundred
and thousand
i like a little too much i
love i love toys i like farming
and i also like trucks and stuffed
animals
my favorite toy is the barbie
and the scooter
baby doll baby doll monster trucks and
dinosaurs
stuffed animals i want to go to the
playroom
i love all these toys
she
what's this dude
go ahead and drive
this is fun
do you feel bad that there's no barbie
no barbies yeah
i am if there's um no
um barbie doll that's okay because i
have barbie dolls at home
too who's that this is kind of a monster
or something
monster truck that's me i'm
evil can you sit in the chair now
where's the chair i can't see
don't replay with this stuff
i don't like it
no
i don't want to play toys
i don't like these toys but i only like
boy stuff
because my mom always likes me to play
with
boy stuff not girl stuff why don't you
sit in that chair
right behind you i want
that white chair
about my big ah
where's my treasure
[Music]
everything get in the house
do you want to try the scooty
i don't know scooters
what toys were you expecting when i said
that you're going to enter
monster trucks and hot wheels
no it's not my favorite color
[Music]
do you want to leave
do you want to play dolls with me yeah i
would be her
yes look peppa pig oh that's cool
[Music]
you guys all bought the same
i want to play with those superheroes
i'll be spider-man i will be
there's no wonder woman
oh man
[Music]
hi guys did you like your toys is
everybody's favorite toy
barbies
[Music]
lyric what is your favorite toy a
monster trucks and cars
[Music]
let me do a trick
heh